on s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
la santé et de la prévention monsieur le
ministre la situation financière des
hôpitaux est particulièrement
inquiétante c'est le cas de mon hôpital
local appareil Monial mais plus
généralement de tous les hôpitaux
publics l'ensemble des hôpitaux quelle
que soit leur taille doit faire face à
des charges qui augmentent plus vite que
le recettes le retour de l'inflation
entraîne par exemple un surcoût de 750
millions d'euros annuels un nom d'âme
fixé pour 2023 à 4% ne permet même pas
de faire face au surcoût généré par
l'inflation des charges générales
hôtelière et énergétiques qui s'envolent
à cela s'ajoute pour les hôpitaux de
proximité qui ne parviennent pas à
recruter des praticiens permanents le
recours à des praticiens intérimaires ce
qui représente là aussi un surcoût élevé
quant à la hausse légitime du point
d'indice de 3,5% des personnels elle
représente une dépense supplémentaire
annuelle de 2 milliards d'euros qui n'a
pas été compensé par l'État
avec un long court national de la dette
de 30 milliards d'euros trois fois plus
qu'en 2002 un nombre croissant
d'établissements et dans l'obligation
d'emprunter beaucoup d'hôpitaux sont
également à ce jour amenés à suspendre
le règlement des taxes sur salaire pour
pouvoir payer leur fournisseurs si je
salue la reprise de la dette
hospitalière par l'État pour 13
milliards et l'affectation de 6
milliards consacrés dans le plan de
relance à l'investissement la situation
des hôpitaux malgré une activité
inégalée est à ce point dégradé que
cette enveloppe globale est totalement
insuffisante pour permettre aux hôpitaux
d'assurer une prise en charge
satisfaisante des patients quant au
personnel il continue de faire preuve du
même et remarquable dévouement observer
lors de la crise sanitaire mais
travaillant dans des conditions très
difficiles ils sont épuisés et au bord
de la rupture cette situation ne peut
plus durer notre système hospitalier a
besoin d'un vaste plan de refondation il
y a urgence vital Marc noiset qui vous a
succédé à la tête de samu-francurgence
évalue à 150 le nombre de patients morts
aux urgences sur des bancales sur le
seul mois de décembre 2022 merci
Monsieur le Ministre
merci beaucoup